JOHN: What I'd like to do
this afternoon is to introduce
Ozalp Babaoglu, who is a full
professor at Bologna Computer
Science and Engineering.
And he's going to
be talking to us
about some stuff around his
ideas around sustainable
computing with data science.
Thank you.
OZALP BABAOGLU: Thank you, John.
I'd like to thank,
also, also Eric Schmidt,
who organized our social
visit to Google today,
with my family.
First time I'm here at Google,
and I'm very, very delighted
to be here.
Thank John for
organizing the talk.
So what I want to do is present
to you some ideas that we have.
And this is joint work with
my post-doc Alina Sirbu.
Questions regarding how
to make high performance
computing sustainable.
And the main point I want
to get through to you
is the use of data science,
and data-driven techniques.
So HPC, High-Performance
Computing,
has this holy grail
of exascale computing,
which is 10 to the 18th
operations per second.
This is picked as a goal
because it's commonly
believed that at that rate
of-- that speed of computing
we could have machines
come close to the power
of the human brain.
So this is seen as a holy grail.
[CHIME]
Now the initial timeline
for reaching this goal
was set to 2018,
but recently it's
been pushed forward due to
all of the technical problems
that you can imagine.
So reaching this
goal in HPC obviously
requires significant
advances initially.
First, in hardware technologies
like raw processing power.
Also parallelization techniques
at the hardware level
and at the software level,
because to get to these speeds,
obviously we need
massive parallelization.
Both in the number of computers
and also in the software
threads.
So we imagine millions
of computing elements
with billions of threads
to achieve the goal.
And the other issues have to
do with power efficiency, power
dissipation, and just
the sheer management
and control of this entire
infrastructure because
of the scale.
And what I'm trying to convey
today is that these problems,
to address them, we really need
to have a holistic approach.
That is, we cannot concentrate
on subsystems in isolation,
but need to look at the
big picture in its whole.
So what I want to do is relate
this problem, perhaps to you,
and Google, in that I believe
that many of the issues having
to do with HPC reaching
exascale performance
can be related also
to large data centers.
Which, I think,
makes the problem
quite relevant to an
audience such as yourself.
Because a large data centers
essentially replicate many
of the problems that
exascale HPC computing
does, especially with regard
to management and control.
So this is a data center,
in the right lower corner.
But what I want to
do with this picture
is just put that
in context to you.
And this is what I mean
by a holistic approach.
That is, we don't want to
look at the data center
in isolation, because it's
part of a huge ecosystem that
includes many, many,
many other elements.
And I indicated some of
them in the block diagram,
having to do with, all the
way from the power generation
station that provides the
electrical power, to get it up
to the data center,
the backup UPS
facilities, the seismic security
having to do with earthquakes,
and the entire non-negligible--
on the contrary,
quite a considerable
part of a data center
has to do with the cooling.
So we need to dissipate all
of the heat that's generated.
So the data center
itself is only
a tiny piece of
this big picture.
So what I'm advocating is that
the sustainability question
really needs to be addressed
looking at the big picture,
and not concentrating just
on the computing element.
So how do we do
management today,
at least in the context
of a data center?
Well, these are some
of the tools that have
been developed over the years.
I've listed some of them.
And many of them have been
developed right here at Google,
by people like John.
What I can say is that
most of these tools
help us in automating some of
the low-level infrastructure
provisioning and
resource allocation.
But even at their best, the
human element, the operator,
remains an integral part of
the management structure.
That is, we cannot completely
take the human element out
of the loop.
And if we want to scale these
data centers to millions
of computing
elements, then we're
going-- if you scale the number
of operators currently employed
in a typical data center by
several orders of magnitude,
we end up with
armies of operators.
And that, I claim,
is not sustainable.
So we need to address that.
And operators in a data center
are quite often detrimental,
rather than useful.
So this is a statistic taken
from a study, the most recent
being 2013.
So this is ranking
the root sources
of outages in data centers.
At the top we have the UPS power
system failure accounts to--
and these are for two
fiscal years, 2013 and 2010.
In the 2013 case,
the power failure
accounts to about a
quarter of the outages.
And if you notice, the second
most common source of outage
is the human element.
So this is the
accidental human error.
So these are the
so-called oops errors
that operators commit while
doing routine maintenance
or update operations.
So this is absolutely not
something that we cannot
ignore.
And if we increase the number
of operators in the data center,
this percentage can
only get bigger.
So the role of operators--
this is a quote,
I'll just read it to you. "One
of the biggest opportunities
for entrepreneurs
in the enterprise
is cutting out
the human IT staff
and going full
automation, potentially
with technologies
like deep learning.
It's ridiculous to have humans
manage the level of complexity
that we have inside
the data center."
And the quote is
due to Vinod Khosla,
who I'm sure many of you know.
He's a noted venture
capitalist and technologist,
one of the founders
of Sun Microsystems.
And this was something he
said at a meeting in 2014.
So this vision of
the human operator
in the data center
as being detrimental
is something that's shared.
It's not just my
paranoia, but it's also
shared by other people.
So what I want to propose
is a shift from human-driven
to data-driven.
And so, certainly, progress
in hardware technologies
is going to be fundamental
and necessary for scaling up
both the center and HPC.
But we also need to scale up
the software technologies.
In particular, in the form
of-- in the management arena,
so as to get the role
of-- we redefine the role
of human operators in
the data center shifting
from nuts and bolts operations,
to setting up high level goals
and objectives.
So the human element
in the data center
should only be setting
high level goals,
and let the software
technologies
that we develop do the routine
maintenance operations.
And at that point we'll have
large computing centers and HP
systems.
Their operations should be based
on predictive computational
models of things
through data science,
and that's what I'm going to
be concentrating on today.
So what I want to
do in this talk
is give you one data point
towards this objective
of achieving
shifting from human-
to data-driven techniques.
And I will do that by focusing
on the aspect of sustainability
that has to do with
long-lasting computations.
That is, computations,
to be sustainable,
should not be
interrupted by events
such as errors or failures.
So the question that I'm
trying to-- the hypothesis
that I'm trying to test is, can
we use data that is contained
in routine typical data
logs that are collected
in typical data centers,
can we use that information
to build predictive models
to be useful towards
the sustainability goal?
And the sustainability
goal for this talk
is going to failure
detection, failure prediction.
But in general we can use
the same techniques, also,
for other aspects
of sustainability
having to do with energy
consumption, and cooling,
and other aspects.
And I've indicated,
through other work
that we have done
exactly in this arena,
having to do with building
predictive models for power
consumption in a HPC setting,
not in a data center setting,
but an HPC setting.
One collected from an IBM
Blue Gene/Q installation
that we have access
to in Bologna.
And the second one being a
research machine, again built
in Bologna, called the Aurora.
That is a hybrid HPC
system that puts together
CPUs, GPUs, and mix to
achieve very high performance.
So what I propose is a
form of autonomic computing
that I call
data-driven autonomics.
And it's based on the idea
that, just as I showed you
in the picture, the data center
is not an object in isolation,
but it's embedded in a
data-rich environment.
The data-rich environment
can be as large as you want.
It can include the
cooling power structure.
But it can also include
the physical environment,
like the seismic activity,
automobile traffic
in the arena, it
can even include
geopolitical considerations
that take place in that arena.
And earthquakes, why not?
So it can be as large as you
want by bringing in more data
sources into the consideration.
So the question is
then, can these data
be exploited to devise a
new class of autonomics
that I call
data-driven autonomics?
So what are the main salient
points of such an autonomic
computing system?
Well, first of
all, as I said, it
should be holistic, meaning
that it should consider the data
center not in isolation,
but in the bigger picture.
And the bigger
picture, as I said,
can be as big as you want,
depending on what you bring in.
It should be data-driven.
It should use modern
data science techniques
to exploit massive amounts
of data that are collected
from multiple sources.
It should be predictive,
as opposed to descriptive.
It should be
predictive in that it
should anticipate
unwanted future states so
that we can avoid them.
It should be rule-based,
interpret the predictions
in the context of larger
high-level policies.
It should be proactive,
rather than reactive.
That is, it should anticipate
unwanted, undesired states,
and avoid them in
the first place,
rather than reacting to them
after they have occurred.
And the ultimate
goal, as I said,
is to limit the role
of the human operator.
So in that sense,
these goals are
very similar to what we have for
things like self-driving cars.
I can list, essentially, the
same properties that we list
for a self-driving vehicle.
Predictive,
rule-based, proactive.
So what I want to do is
apply these same ideas
in the case of sustainable
high-performance computing.
So what we did was test this
idea on one particular data
that we have access to, which
happens to be the Google
dataset that John has
collected and made publicly
available for researchers.
So this is just a very
short summary of that data.
Maybe I'm boring you.
You probably know some of this.
But anyway, it's a
dataset collected
from about 12,000 machines
over a one month period.
It's roughly 200
gigabytes of raw data.
And the data contains
elements that
have to do with task
events, regarding
the state and the number
of tasks on each machine.
It includes the task usage logs
having to do with the resource
consumption of each task.
And then machine
events that indicate
when machines are added or
removed from the cluster,
either due to failures or
due to maintenance events.
So what we did was use this
data and apply machine learning
techniques to build
a predictive model.
And the first thing we did
was to select the features.
So the first thing we
did, we extracted 12,
what I call base features,
over five minute windows.
And the 12 basic features
are the number of running,
started, finished,
failed, killed, evicted,
lost tasks on each machine.
So these are the
different states
that a task can be
on for each machine.
And we count the number of tasks
in each one of those states.
We also add to the feature
set the machine load
in the form of average CPU load,
the memory load, the cycles
per instruction--
the CPI-- load,
the memory accesses per
instruction, and the disk time.
So these are all
available in the raw data,
so we extract these on 5
minute intervals per machine,
and then aggregate them.
And then we also compute
aggregate features.
These are averages and
standard deviations
and coefficient of variations
over longer intervals.
Not five minutes, but longer.
Longer being 1, 12, 24,
48, 72, and 96 hours.
And then, finally, we
select seven features,
and compute pairwise
correlations between them.
So this adds 21 more features,
if you do the seven choose
two, that's 21.
So this adds 21 more features.
So in the end, we end up
with 416 total features,
accounting to a very modest
amount of data, 104 megabytes.
So the size of the data
is not an issue at all.
[CLICK]
So this is a-- sorry.
This is a picture
of a time series
of some of these
features for one
particular node in that 12,000
cluster that we have access to.
So this is time
running horizontally.
And the features
that I'm illustrating
with the various
colors happen to be
the CPU load at the
5 minute interval,
the CPU load, but now at
the 12 hour average, the CPU
load at the 12 hour
coefficient of variation,
and then the pairwise CPU
load running job 12 hour
correlation.
The actual values are
not terribly important.
I'm just showing you what
a typical time series
data looks like.
But what I'm also
showing is that big gap
in the middle, that white space.
For this particular
node that I'm examining,
that node happens to have been
removed at around 250 hours,
and then added back into the
cluster at 350 hours, roughly.
So in that interval
the node was absent,
either because it
failed, or it was
undergoing some sort of
update maintenance operation.
So then we analyze
these features
using one of your
tools, BigQuery,
that we have access to.
So we did preprocessing of
the features using BigQuery.
These are some features of
BigQuery that I'll skip,
because I'm sure
you know about them.
I'll only highlight the fact
that the whole preprocessing
operation on BigQuery
costs less than $2,000
using real Google pricing.
So this is something quite--
it's not an unreasonable
amount of expense.
AUDIENCE: Highway robbery.
OZALP BABAOGLU: Excuse me?
[LAUGHTER]
AUDIENCE: I said
highway robbery.
OZALP BABAOGLU: Highway robbery.
And this is a more detailed
breakdown of the BigQuery
preprocessing in terms
of-- the first column
are the aggregation interval,
ranging from one hour
up to 96 hours.
And then the second column
is the resulting data size,
ranging from a
10th of a terabyte
all the way up to
12.5 terabytes.
And then the last two
columns are the actual times
required to compute the
average standard deviation
coefficient of variation,
which is the third column.
And the last column, which
is the most time-consuming
computation, having to do
with the pairwise coefficient
of variation computation.
This is interesting because
it's-- at least as far as I
know, it's one of the
first quantitative results
of BigQuery performance
on real data.
In itself, it's not really
relevant to what I'm doing,
but it's just
giving us a feeling
for the performance of BigQuery,
which we were very, very
happy to use.
I mean, it made
our work feasible.
Otherwise, if we were to do
this on local infrastructure,
we would not have
been able to do it.
So now, continuing on to
what I want to get at,
which is a predictive
model for failures.
The first thing we
need to recognize
is the fact that the
Google trace does not
have failure events.
There is nothing in the Google
trace that's labeled a failure.
There are machine ads
and machine removes--
node adds and node removes.
So failures can only be inferred
indirectly, and approximately,
because obviously we
don't have certainty.
And here we consulted John
on how we might do this.
So we came up with the
following heuristic,
which was, if a machine
remove event is not succeeded
within the next two hours by
the same node being added,
we deem it to be a failure.
So the reasoning being, if
it were a routine maintenance
or an update event,
the node would
be removed from the
cluster, but then would
reappear in the cluster after
some reasonable amount of time.
And we chose two hours to be
this reasonable amount of time.
Now you can question
that, obviously.
And I don't have
any specific reason
why that should be the--
but again, as I said,
this was not something that we
made up completely on our own.
We consulted our
colleagues here.
So take that as it may.
So less than two
hours is considered
a routine maintenance event.
If it's more than
two hours we assume
that the machine failed, and
then was somehow repaired
and put back into the cluster.
So this is going to be
my definition of what
a failure is.
So at that point we
classify each data
point as either a fail, which
I call the positive class,
and safe, which is
the negative class.
So in terms of the
classifier language,
the positive class
corresponds to the failures
and the negative
class corresponds
to safe or nonfailure.
So a fail, a positive
event, is considered
to be some-- time to failure
is less than 24 hours.
So we chose a window of a day.
So if the machine happens to
be labeled in the failure state
within a day, we call that data
point to be in the fail class.
And if it's greater
than 24 hours,
it's considered to
be in the safe class.
Is that clear?
OK.
And the resulting
number of data points
were given in the
previous slide.
So we end up with some 100--
I should go back to that,
because that's important.
Sorry.
So doing this, we end up
with 108,000 positive events,
meaning failure events.
And we end up with half
a million safe events,
but that's only after a half
a percent random sampling.
Because if we don't do
the random sampling,
the number of safe
states is overwhelming,
because most of the time
failures don't occur.
So you have machines there
that typically don't fail.
So if we were to keep
all of the safe states,
then the two classes would
be extremely unbalanced,
and most of the machine
learning techniques that we use
do not perform well
when you do a classifier
with such different
ratios of the two states.
So we do a half a
percent subsampling,
meaning that we throw away
95% of the safe states,
and we pick a random
half a percent sample.
Sorry, not 95.
99.5% are thrown out,
and the half a percent
are randomly sampled and
kept as the safe state.
So the classifier itself is
a Random Forest classifier.
This is a well-known
machine learning technique
based on decision trees.
I'll go very fast here,
since I assume most of you
are familiar with
these techniques.
So we generate a large set
of Random Forest classifiers,
and we train them, and then
we compute their precision
of each one, based
on a dataset which
is different from the dataset
we used to do the evaluation.
So the test dataset is
divided into halves.
The individual dataset, which is
used to compute the precision,
and the ensemble dataset, which
is used to build the ensemble
classifier through precision
weighted voting, which I
will explain in the next slide.
So we end up with 420 individual
Random Forest classifiers,
and we built them as follows.
We varied the number of decision
trees between two and 15,
so there are 14 of them.
We varied the ratio between
safe and fail data events
between a quarter and four.
So this determines the number
of subsampling percentage
that I talked about
just a few minutes ago.
So we either throw
out more or less
of the safe data
between those intervals.
And then we repeat the
whole thing five times.
So when you do all of the
math you end up with 420.
So we end up with
420 RF classifiers,
and we train each of them
on 10 consecutive days,
and then we test on
the next disjoint day.
So remember the Google data
trace has 29 days of data.
So if you look at the picture in
the bottom-- so for benchmark 1
we skip the first two
days, because we want
the aggregate to start working.
Because if we do aggregation
over the previous days,
if we start from day zero,
we don't have anything
to aggregate.
So we start in day three.
So the blue days are
the training data.
Then we skip a day.
And then on the 11th day,
that's our test date.
And we do this by shifting this
picture one day to the right,
and we end up with 15 benchmarks
that cover the entire 29
days of the trace.
So these are the-- we have 15
benchmarks to do the testing.
So going back to the
ensemble classifier,
we had 420 classifiers,
and we merge all of them
into an ensemble classifier.
So we have ensembles
of ensembles.
Because remember,
Random Forest itself
is an ensemble, because it's
based on individual trees which
are built into a forest.
So we have a forest of
forests, 420 of them.
And we combined them
by doing a weighted sum
based on the precision.
So we take-- if you take the
Ith random forest classifier
and take its output, which
is shown as sigma IJ, which
is a binary value
indicating it's either
in the fail or the safe state.
So for the data point
J. And we compute
the precision of
the Ith classifier,
that's indicated as PI.
And then the weighted sum of
the output with the precision
summed over all of the 420
classifiers is labeled SJ.
So the SJ value is no
longer a binary value.
It's a real value,
because we scale it
by the appropriate value so we
get a number between 0 and 1,
so that we can interpret
it as a probability.
So the weighted
value now can be seen
as a likelihood of failure.
So it's not a binary classifier.
It's not one zero, but
it's a real number.
So closer to one is
more likely to fail.
Closer to 0 is less
likely to fail.
So this is the
ensemble classifier.
So now the prediction-- yeah.
So the weighting is
done only on the outputs
of the individual classifiers
as I have defined the states.
So you're right that
some of the outputs
may be missing, because
we simply did not
consider-- those are excluded.
I don't know what else to say.
They're not included
in the ensemble.
And obviously this will have
a consequence on the-- yeah.
But we'll see the
evaluation results
and you can judge whether
it's good enough or not.
So now the prediction
of failure now becomes
a classification problem.
And by applying
the model you just
evaluate the ensemble classifier
for a particular data point.
And then you
interpret the result
as the likelihood of a failure.
OK?
Then we can now convert this
back to a binary classifier
by setting a threshold.
So you can say, if the
likelihood is more than 80%,
I'll consider the
output to be a failure.
So the training was done
on an absolutely ordinary
routine desktop computer.
A very moderate
performance iMac.
And this was just to show
you that the training is
a very lightweight operation.
It took between seven and
nine hours on a single desktop
computer.
So we don't need any sort
of high-power computing
to do the training.
So these are the results.
So the results for
a binary classifier
is typical to display
these ROC curves that I'm
sure you're familiar with.
So here I'm plotting
the true positive rate
in the vertical
axis as a function
of the false positive rate.
So the true positive
rate is the number
of positives that are actually
classified as positive.
And the horizontal
scale is the number
of negatives that are
identified as positive.
So these are the false
alarms, if you will.
So ideally we want to be in
the upper left hand corner,
because you want the
true positive to be one,
and you want the false
positive to be zero.
But obviously life
is more complicated,
so we get these curves.
So the solid line is
the ensemble classifier.
And I'm showing you this for
two different benchmarks,
the left one being
the best case.
Remember, we had 15 benchmarks?
So this is the 14th
among those 15.
And the worst case happens
to be benchmark number four,
on the right.
So let's look at the best case.
So the solid line is the
ensemble classifier, it
and the individual colored
dots are the individual pieces
of the ensemble.
And the colors correspond
to different ratios
among the false fail
and safe events.
Remember I defined
this-- I told you
we were doing the subsampling
and we were varying it
between a quarter and four?
So these are the
different colors.
The dark blue is the 0.25.
And the whatever that
color-- that is yellow--
is the case when the ratio is 4.
4 to 1 as opposed
to a quarter to one.
But anyway, the take away is
that the ensemble typically
performs better than the
individual classifiers, which
is good.
So it means that by putting
individual classifiers together
under a single ensemble we do
better than any one of them
individually, because
rarely any of the dots
are above the solid line.
And the other encouraging
point is the curve.
Even though it's not ideal,
it's close to our desire,
which is being in the
upper right hand corner.
And it's typical to pick the
false positive rate to be 5%.
And if you do that-- so that's
the yellow vertical line,
this point here-- you end up
with the true positive rate
in the best case to be 88% and
in the worst case to be 27%.
Now the other evaluation
of a predictive model
is the precision recall curves.
So these are plotting
the precision,
meaning what is the probability
that an event marked
as a failure is really a failure
as a function of the recall,
which is the true positive rate.
And in this case we
would like the curve
to be essentially
a horizontal line,
and then dropping off to zero.
And here were we do less well.
The best case looks
pretty reasonable,
but the worst case is
significantly below the ideal.
And in this case we
also see that some
of the individual
members of the ensemble
do better than the ensemble,
at least for the worse case.
But again, if we pick the
5% false positive rate
as a threshold, we end up with
the precision recall values
that range from 72% and 50%.
So just summing up, if we
limit the false alarms to 5%,
in the best case we can identify
almost 90% of the failures.
And 72% of those failures that
are identified as failures
are indeed failures.
And in the worst case we are
able to identify only 30%
of the events as failures.
And in that case, about half
of them are actually failures.
So this sums up the evaluation.
You can also summarize them as
these areas on the ROC and PR
curves, but I'll skip that.
[CLICK]
So next you may ask, well,
prediction is not perfect.
Sometimes we misclassify
events, so how bad
are the misclassifications?
So how wrong are they?
So the classes for the fail
class, the positive class--
remember, we identify
the fail class
as being a failure occurring
within the next 24 hours.
So an event would be
included in the fail class
if the failure occurred even
one minute in the future,
or 23 hours into the future,
because both of those
are within the next day.
But intuitively, obviously
those two scenarios
would be very different.
If you have a failure
coming up in a minute,
as opposed to 23 hours, perhaps
you would do different things.
So classifying both
of them as failure
should not be--
technically it is correct,
but qualitatively they
should be seen differently.
And likewise, in
the negative case,
the failure is outside
of the 24 hour window.
If it occurs at 24
hours and 1 minute,
as opposed to two weeks.
Again, technically both
of those are safe states,
but again, intuitively
you perhaps might
do different things
in those two cases.
How do the classifiers
perform in practice?
I'm showing you this
for the benchmark four.
So these are box
plots for the time,
hours to next remove event.
Hours to next remove event
as a function of-- I'm
showing you the true positive
and the false negative.
So on the left
picture, these are
the case when the event
is marked as a failure.
Either because it's
a true positive,
a failure, or it's incorrectly
marked as a failure
even though it was a safe event.
So the thing to note is that
the case when the true positive
median-- the red line in
the bow of the bow tie
is the median value.
In the case of TP
the true positive
is lower than the
false negative.
So what that means is that in
the case of a failure that's
actually marked as a
failure, we mark it
as a failure closer to
the failure than if it
were a misclassification.
Now why is that good?
Well, if the event is
misclassified as a failure
later, that means
that you have more
time to-- because
remember, we're
doing this at 5
minute intervals.
So we have more opportunity
to mark it correctly
in the future.
So we mark it as a failure
if it's further away,
because that gives us more
time to classify it correctly
in the future.
If it were misclassified
and it was imminent,
then the classification
would be wrong
and that's all there is to it.
So misclassification,
if it's further away,
is deemed to be better,
because as I said,
it gives us more chance
to classify it correctly
in the future.
And I'll skip the right curve.
So putting all this
together, how would you
use such a predictive model?
Well, you would perhaps use
it to do some intelligent form
of scheduling.
So one idea would be to define
this notion of a quarantine.
So a node that it is
classified as a failure in two
consecutive evaluations, we
put it into a quarantine state.
And if a machine is in
the quarantine state
the scheduler does not
dispatch any tasks to it.
Tasks that would be
dispatched to that node
are diverted to other nodes.
Now, when you do that,
two things could happen.
You could redirect a
task to a node that
is in the quarantine
state, but the failure
was sufficiently ahead, such
that the task would have
finished before the failure.
So that's bad.
It means that you redirected
a task without reason.
You could have avoided that.
Or be you could have
redirected the task
and it would have
been interrupted.
That is, while it was running
you would have had the failure.
And you avoided
that interruption,
so that's the good case.
So we have these two outputs.
The redirected
without reason is bad.
And recovered is what
I call the second case,
meaning that you
avoided dispatching
the job to a node which
was in the quarantine.
And that's the good case.
And you obviously want
to-- your objective
is to minimize the redirected
and maximize the recovered.
Obviously, if you
redirect everybody,
nobody will be interrupted
and the recovered
will be as high as possible.
But you would have-- that would
be like taking that node out
of the picture altogether,
so that's obviously
something you want to avoid.
So you want to keep the
node in the cluster,
but you just want to
avoid sending tasks to it
that you know will
be interrupted.
So we evaluated this idea.
But to do the evaluation
we needed a base case.
And the base case was defined
to be the result of these two
events, recovered
and redirected,
if we had a perfect predictor.
Meaning that, suppose we could
predict failures perfectly
within the next 24 hours,
that is 24 hours in advance.
So if a failure can be predicted
perfectly a day in advance,
that case is what I'm taking
as my baseline, the best case.
So doing that, we end up
with pictures like this.
So here I'm plotting
tasks that are recovered
in the top left picture.
So the solid line at the
top is the base case,
and the three dotted
curves correspond
to our real predictive
model for varying amounts
of false positive rates.
So we considered false positive
rates of 5%, 1%, and 2%.
So if you, for
example, as a function
of the quarantine window
size, if you take 250
as a concrete value, because
we take that because here
we match the
baseline in the case
of false positive rate of 2%.
And the resulting
task recovered for 250
happens to be about
half of the baseline.
So if you limit the false
positive rates to 2%
and your number of
redirected tasks
are as good as in the baseline,
then you can recover about half
of the tasks that you would
if you had a perfect 24 hour
predictor.
And the right hand curves
are the same two situations,
but in terms of CPU hours
that are redirected and saved,
as opposed to the
number of tasks.
OK?
Now there's some technical
details here which
I've skipped, but they're
included in the paper
there if you want
to look at them.
Because the Google trace
also has different classes
of the tasks depending
on their length.
So we're only doing
this for the class
zero, the short-running tasks.
And we're not looking at the
long-running production tasks.
So I skipped a lot
of detail here.
So again, now going
back to the big picture,
how could you put
these ideas and build
an autonomic controller?
So first of all, an autonomic
data-driven controller,
I claim, should have
these requirements.
It should be closed, in
the sense that it should
run on the same
infrastructure that you're
trying to control
and not require
an infrastructure of its own.
That is, to control
a data center
you don't want to build
another data center next to it
to do the management.
That's obviously something
that you want to avoid.
It should be non-intrusive.
That is, the load
that it generates
should be quite modest and
not be an overwhelming strain
on the data center.
And it should run in real time.
That is, it should
run on data that's
being streamed to it
as data is generated,
and do the prediction
for the future.
So we did a feasibility
study of this idea.
So the monitoring system
to do the live streaming
of the data directly
to BigQuery, at least
for the amount of
data that we analyzed,
would require only
$0.25 per day.
And every 5 minutes recompute
features in parallel
will require about 2/10
of a second per feature.
And to store the previously
computed features
for the last 12
days would require
about 122 gigabytes of storage.
And adding all of this up
at real Google pricing this
would end up being about
$60 a day, which is nothing.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, so one
question I have is,
are you taking
into consideration
the failure of the
autonomic controller itself?
OZALP BABAOGLU: Yeah,
that's a good question.
Obviously the autonomic
controller itself
is running on the
infrastructure which
you are trying to
control and predict,
and that's obviously subject
to the same type of events.
So could it also
fail, in which case
you would have to replicate
some of the pieces so as to--
in this computation I'm
not considering that.
So yes, if that's a
concern you would obviously
render the autonomic
controller fault tolerant
by using the appropriate
techniques of replication.
AUDIENCE: OK.
OZALP BABAOGLU: But
that's not included here.
So once you have
the features, you
would build the model from
the last 12 days of data,
and then train it
on the data itself.
Again, based on real numbers
from something like the Compute
Engine that would require
about three minutes per Random
Forest.
Again, quite a reasonable
amount of time.
And then once you have the
model, applying it every five
minutes after computing the
features, applying the model
is really negligible.
It's extremely lightweight
and doesn't really
require any heavy
computation, so I didn't even
put a number for that.
So the conclusion being that
the feasibility, at least
for the dimensions, the
sizes that we considered,
are quite practical.
It's not something
that's infeasible.
You could easily run it on
a typical infrastructure
at costs that are
really very contained.
So the takeaway points that
I try to communicate to you
are the following.
Autonomic controllers
need to be data-driven,
and we can use modern
data science techniques
to help us build
them to overcome
some of the challenges
of scale and complexity.
I have outlined such a
data-driven autonomic
controller to you.
Not in infinite detail, but a
very high level description.
And the other main point
that I want to get across
is that data that are
contained in typical logs, that
are collected in
HPC or data centers,
are rich enough to build
useful predictive models.
Now, the situation can
only get better if you
were to do this in-house.
Remember, we're doing this from
an outside-- we're not Google.
We use the public
Google trace to do this.
If I were Google
itself I would also--
I could collect more data.
Right?
AUDIENCE: We do.
OZALP BABAOGLU: You do.
[LAUGHTER]
You do.
Unfortunately, most of that is--
AUDIENCE: You don't.
OZALP BABAOGLU: --not
publicly available,
so by using proprietary
in-house more detailed log data
the situation can only
get better, is my point.
And you would obviously do this.
And the other point that I
tried to get across repeatedly
is this holistic approach.
In this particular
work I did not
have any empirical
evidence for that.
But in the energy consumption
predictive modeling work
that I alluded to this holistic
approach is really fundamental.
That is, you don't want to look
at subsystems in isolation,
but you really want to
look at the big picture.
Even by doing
cross-correlation of subsystems
that you did not even
consider it would be related.
By doing the wildest
crossing features
that you thought were completely
irrelevant and unrelated,
by crossing them
together you get
features that are extremely
interesting and important.
And the data-driven
autonomic controller
can be made practical.
So this is three papers that are
related to what I talked about.
And if you want to look at
some of the technical detail,
you can do that by
looking at the papers.
Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Over here.
OZALP BABAOGLU: Oh, sorry.
AUDIENCE: Can you say again how
many remove or true fail events
there were in your dataset?
Was it 100 some?
OZALP BABAOGLU:
Well, I can tell you
the number of remove events.
If by true you mean true
failures, as I said,
I don't know that.
As I defined them, I had the
numbers some slides back.
158,000 I think.
Right.
AUDIENCE: Of the features you
actually had in this dataset,
is there is there one
where, if you took it out,
considerably worsened things?
OZALP BABAOGLU: That's
a good question.
We did the principal component
analysis of the data,
and the conclusion was
that, no, we were not
able to really rank the futures
in any reasonable manner
so that we could keep a subset
and throw out the others.
So even though it might sound
somewhat counterintuitive,
all of the 420 some
features were important,
at least according to the
technique that we were using.
So we could not throw
out any of them.
AUDIENCE: Thank you very much.
OZALP BABAOGLU: Thank you.
Thank you very much.
[APPLAUSE]